i'm not a geek i'm not a council i
am an idiot
hey folks we have reached the
end of series eight of doctor who
for the re-watch on this take two doctor
who review
death in heaven
i'll just kind of jump to the end it's
it's really good
i actually think this two-parter overall
is one of the stronger finishers
for doctor who in general i think
closers can be tough on this
show and oftentimes you end up with
two partners with one half being
significantly better than
the other and it would vary on which was
which
so like i'm of the opinion that in the
case of series one and series two
the second halves were much more much
stronger than the first halves
series three i actually have problems
with that thing overall but first half
was
better than the second series four
second half was a little better but
pretty close series five first half was
way better series six with series six
was just a
mess on that one
series seven you know it's not a
two-parter it's a standalone piece same
with series six for that matter
but here's series eight it is a good
solid story that
progresses great through both tabs and
even taking it
out on its own is a good is a good
way to close it out
including some things that don't stick
and i wish they did
but we'll get to that not the fault of
this episode
we're coming off the back of the reveal
of the cybermen
missy being the master and i like at the
front
unit is there on the
ball now we do find out later that
missy actually lured them there and
that's i mean that's fine she would do
that but
i just like that they're already there
they're not scrambling
they're on top of this already not as on
top of it as they think they are because
they're dealing with missy
but still i like that i like that we
just have units showing up being
competent
at the front end doing the job the way
they are supposed to be doing it
i am totally good with that as a way to
bring them back into the story
now the whole the doctors the president
of the world
thing i don't know about that
part of it is that the fact that he's
the leader of the entire world
never actually impacts the story
because the story never leaves the uk
so all all they would have had to do
was to have missy initially taking over
the uk and that the clouds that she was
setting up those were going to spread
worldwide
and drop the the seeds and everything
all over the place or something to that
effect
there's no reason for the threat to
initially be all over the world although
it doesn't hurt it but then
i figured that's that was the reason why
they made
the doctor the emergency leader of the
entire planet as opposed to just the uk
and i mean there's the there's
logistical thing like do i believe that
the nations of the world would actually
agree to do this
i don't but you know it's a show here
they do
whatever but i just it it doesn't impact
anything
the fact that he's the president of the
world has zero impact on the story so
i'm not entirely sure why it's there
so that's that's a bit of an odd beat i
i really do like michelle gomez's missy
i like her so much she is so
fun and chaotic and in a way that
feels calculated if that makes sense
like dur and at some points when
sim was playing the master he was
chaotic but it felt like in a way like
he
he couldn't control what he was doing
sometimes it it honestly felt like here
it always feels like missy's in control
but the thing she has decided to do
are chaotic so i and i just i kind of
just like that better like
this person is in control of their
faculties
but they are deciding to do things that
do not follow
standard thought processes and so trying
to get ahead of them is
just not really going to work and i like
all that
so the killing of
oz good i got to write this i have so
many videos up where i accidentally call
her oswin it's embarrassing
um but anyways so the killing of oz good
i remember initially not
liking that i kind of it kind of grew on
me as i thought about it over
time as a necessity because what we'd
seen
of missy up to this point lean towards
campy's the wrong word but you know
playful
almost you know she's toying with the
doctor
and you know she's got cybermen out but
she was captured almost immediately
and the cybermen just kind of flew off
when we don't know what they're doing
she doesn't
feel like a threat yet i mean
you know michelle gomez has her presence
obviously everyone's taking her
seriously but she hasn't really
established herself as a threat yet
so killing what was definitely a
character i liked
if you didn't like oz good fine but a
character that so far as i could tell
most of the fans liked
in that way does a really good job of
establishing that
missy may be playful
she may be fun but she is still
dangerous so it does actually serve a
purpose
and it's not just oh we got to make the
villain hate it but like no we need to
establish
the rules for this specific version of
the mask this is always something that
the show doesn't always successfully do
and i'm not just talking new who
sometimes in classic as well
anytime we get introduced to a new
iteration of either the doctor or the
master
they really need to establish the rules
for this version
there are certain inherent things that
you can assume about either one of those
characters but
the specifics you gotta lay that out and
laying out
her you know proving her
to be just as deadly as
any other iteration of the master yeah
they kind of needed to
and to not have it be with faceless
soldiers although
note on that this was really dumb
this was so she's you know she's
handcuffed and she's
taunting um osgood and
you know eventually osgood goes back and
you know reaches into her part and goes
these handcuffs they're not mine and
missy has a line oh they must be mine
and then she lunges at osgood and
kills the soldiers on paper that's fine
practical sense watching it though are
we sure those two guys were soldiers and
not just
mannequins because they never move
so osgood you know finds the
uh handcuffs in her pocket and misty
hands untied
reapplies her lipstick these guys just
stand there
lunges across this room at osgoode and
then turns around and fires her little
beam and kills them and when the beam
hits them
they're still just standing there at
attention
what's it gonna take for you two to move
ah oh god if you notice it which i've
now brought your attention to so
sorry but now you get to experience my
pain at how
stupid that is
okay so bit of a nitpick on that let's
talk
danny and clara because we kind of have
to
let's start with just danny i actually
really like
that they kind of cover all their bases
using him to
illustrate what's going on with the
cybermen so
we have this whole thing of
he did they they pushed him within the
nethersphere
to delete his emotional responses which
would have been him
voluntarily setting the emotional
inhibitor
now i'm not entirely sure why he needs
to agree to do that himself
and why they don't just forcibly do it
to him but i'm prepared to let that bit
go
because that means that because he
didn't
actually get around to doing that when
he gets
uploaded into his cyber converted body
he still feels and it hurts and we've
established that about
cybermen in new who
this existence hurts a lot in addition
to that
everything going on with clara he feels
hurt
from that as well so i feel all of that
was well played and then bringing up you
know her
going to turn on the emotional inhibitor
now
is it a little cheesy that the inhibitor
gets turned on and he still
kind of protects her and doesn't totally
obey orders yeah but
i don't know it it covered in enough of
its bases
that i'm okay with it because
you know the the whole thing establishes
like he shouldn't be feeling in the
first place that shouldn't be going on
at all
and but we have a reason for that so
it's not like the
it's not like the entire scene of him
uh you know being a cyberman is all
about the strength of the human world
like no
the inhibitor's off and then when it
gets turned on you know the stretch for
which
maybe it's that and maybe it's you know
the power of love
whatever is a significantly shorter
chunk of
his being in this situation and i can
roll with it
i can deal with it i get it if some
folks don't i get if it doesn't work for
everybody
oh another random note um we get it
firmly established that missy was the
one who put clara and the doctor
together
uh why like
she says like what a perfect matching
the control freak and the man who won't
be controlled
and i'm like oh okay so it's for
laughs i guess but you're really
committed to it
like you took multiple steps to ensure
that they stayed together
and that for the for all the effort you
put in i think it i feel like it should
have been for more of a reason than that
i don't know if there was going to be a
deeper reason and they just cut it
because it wasn't worth it or if
moffat assumed he would come up with a
deeper reason and never
did i i don't know but i
they there isn't really a solid reason
given at least not
as yet and this is the point in which
they establish it was definitely her who
gave the number
for the doctor's tardis to clara and who
put the ad in the paper for deep breath
like it
we know it's her but
we don't know why like that's confirmed
but why
oh another thing with danny i i don't
know
why but there's something i really liked
about
about his line the promise of a soldier
and then him clarifying what that is
and it felt it rang really true
i'd like i've never served in the
military never had an interest in
serving in the military i've known some
people who
have though and him saying that the
promise of a soldier is you will sleep
safe tonight
that rang really true to me i don't know
if that's an actual motto
for any armed forces but it it rang true
to the mentality of
the people who i have known who have
been voluntarily
involved in some way in the military so
i thought that that was good that was
good stuff
the stuff that goes on with clara and
danny well actually first of all
clara with her whole um i'm the doctor
clara oswald never existed like i get
why she does it
that she's just stalling for time but
the scene
feels very weird honestly it feels like
it was made
only for a next time on doctor who
clip because at the start of our
at the end of in the force of the night
before the beginning of this two-parter
we had
a clip that included that moment
i'm not clara as well clara oswald never
existed
and it feels like they wanted to do that
tease and wrote the scene just so they
just basically for the sake of a trailer
because
i get that she's babbling to talk her
way out of it but
there's i don't get why she's saying
what she's saying and i know it's not
foreshadowing to the idea that
she's going to start behaving more like
the doctor and that's ultimately uh
gonna be sort of her
path in series nine which it is but she
was supposed to leave at the end of this
series this was supposed to be the
emperor but jenna coleman decided to
stay on longer
so i know it's not intentional
foreshadowing for that at the time so i
don't know why
that was written it's not particularly
clever and it's just
it's just awkward enough to feel like
that's just trailer bait
isn't it but her interactions with danny
they they feel solid they work i think
is mainly sold by the actors
the performers uh they they make it work
the cyber break that is really
just odd and kind of cheesy but i
like it i don't know why it actually
kind of choked me up a little bit
the doctor saluting
to this cyberized version of the
brigadier
who saved his daughter maybe it's
because i'm a parent and i have a
daughter that might honestly just
be all there is to it but
i did i did i did like that and it
it felt like a nice additional final
note for the brig
having acknowledged uh nicholas
courtney's passing
back in series six
so that this this was just nice i
enjoyed that
um so
the doctor's speech at the end there's a
reason i quoted i am an idiot
at the start of this that
statement that he makes you know i'm not
a
soldier i'm not a president i am an
idiot
with a screwdriver passing through
and helping out that to me is the
mission statement of the version of the
doctor that i
love best and i don't just mean capaldi
i mean
the way that the doctor gets handled as
a character that is how he was handled
for pretty much
all of classic who and it's what i enjoy
best as turn in terms of how the
character gets approached because
the character's importance has gotten
inflated over time it got inflated
during tenants run it got supercharged
during smith's
and here in capaldi's i like this sort
of
restatement of purpose of
i he's not the end-all all he's just
he's just a person passing through
trying to help
that's it that's what i want out of my
doctor and i
love hearing capaldi say those words i
love it
i absolutely adore it and i also like
that missy just gives them the army with
her motivation being i want my friend
back
she feels alone and she wants an
assurance that
she isn't and this is how she's decided
to try and get it
the whole like oh missy gets killed like
i didn't buy that for an instant not
even first time i saw it i'm like she
teleported
like that even looked the same as when
she teleported earlier the same episode
yeah and of course i was right but they
don't try and
play it off like uh like a huge grand
thing when she comes back
next series so speaking of next series
so i really i really really
really like the end
where clara
lies to the doctor saying that danny
came back
when in truth he sent back the
kid that he killed in accidentally in
combat the civilian casualty
and that the doctor lies to her that he
found califray
i love this scene of them each line to
the other to try and spare them
pain when both of them are in
very similar pain of having to swallow a
loss and thinking that they were going
to get something back
and it got taken away from them
but in trying to spare the other one
pain
they lied they both lie to each other
and i wish i
wish that had been it i think that would
have been a brilliant way to close out
their story because something that i'm
something that i'm learning and i'm
gonna keep a very careful eye on this
as i go through series nine the doctor
and clara
compel these doctors specifically aren't
actually good for each other
they're kind of toxic together
they kind of bring out the worst
parts of each other and i don't mean
that in the traditional toxic
relationship of like they yell and
scream and hit each other
or you know or whatever but
she pushes him in such a way that he is
willing to he is willing to entertain
notions or to do
things or to consider doing things that
the doctor wouldn't normally do
and she is so headstrong that she can
get him to do things that he just
shouldn't
they're toxic in that way and
i am gonna keep an eye on that to see
how that tracks over series nine
in terms of leading up to
hell bent and we'll see if that
perspective makes that
episode go down any better for me i
doubt it
but we'll see and i guess
what i mean when i say this would have
been a great ending is like this would
have been a really fitting way
for a toxic relationship to end in the
least dramatic fashion possible
they just both lie to each other and
walk away
and it's it's tough with toxic
relationships they can be
rough for me to watch especially
prolonged
uh and i kind of would have liked this
relationship to have
closed out there it didn't got last
christmas coming up
but before that i've got i've got to do
a ranking of these episodes there's
other stuff to do but
that's death in heaven i do like i have
my nitpicks clearly
when do i not but i did really like it
have you rewatched it lately what you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it you know all the
stuff to do
like subscribe support me on patreon
that's kind of the big one
it is uh it's what's paying the bills
right now
barely actually not really quite
covering them but
um working on that so all that stuff
you know what it is that i've also got
merch and links to social media
all those things but you also don't have
to
end of the day you are the council i'm
just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]